ich
hab ihnen tamagotchi munter haben sehe
ich gerade
allerdings befinde ich mich auf irgend
einer einsamen insel
und damit darf ich euch recht herzlich
willkommen heißen zu arg meine lieben
freude das ist ein dinosaurier spiel und
wir haben schon direkt den ersten die no
hi
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob der
freundlich ist
da kommt direkt letzte das sind pq wie
nas
pgp babbel
was wollen die denn
kann ich durch mit inventar scrollen das
braucht
ja gut wenn ich jemanden sehen würde der
aussieht wie kim kardashian in
dinosaurier land würde ich
wahrscheinlich den auch radfahren
verfolgt mich jetzt die ganze was ist
wenn ich schneller laufen immer noch
hinter mir die warten wir jetzt aber was
wollen die denn
ich weiß nicht was du willst aber ich
kann es dir nicht geben ich kann nicht
mehr durch mit inventar scrollt dann
irgendwann irgendwie sicht oder so
ich las den da jetzt einfach mal liegen
und
was ist das
[Musik]
ein manta rochen
ach der ist tot
ich kann ihnen
ja ich wollte hier ein schäbiges projekt
starten dass wir irgendwo und sie
bisschen umgucken können wir das spiel
so schön aussieht und was ist das
wieso ist denn da plötzlich so
[Musik]
viel ist tabu
ich dachte das ist ein ganz entspanntes
spiel wir starten hier rein müssen uns
wie in minecraft irgendwie vielleicht
ein bisschen holz holen oder
sonnencremes aber wir sind direkt in dem
kanzlerin was will denn mister bern sda
hinten die ganze zeit
19 von mir weg oder hinter mir her gehen
halter der lizenz
längst tot
ist es mein herz ich hab'
ich habe ein knochenbruch kim ky läuft
auch nicht mehr so wie davor aber egal
ich komme hier bisschen gegen baum gegen
obwohl das macht vielleicht nicht besser
mit knochenbrüchen bruder es tut mir
leid ich kann dir nicht helfen
ich habe mich selbst getötet ist ja
nicht so dass da gerade drei kleinen
tick trick und track wieder ankam und
mir ins bein abgerissen haben aber gut
leute klicken wir mal auf respawn
er macht jetzt wieder einfach random aus
dem nichts auf
es ist ja diese scheiss mantarochen gott
freunde ich will mir erst einen kleinen
überblick verschaffen über dieses diesen
ort wo wir hier sind also das hier ist
kim ky im wasser wir haben auf jeden
fall eine fesche unterhose an von calvin
klein müssen uns allerdings erstmal
darum kümmern dass wir uns ein bisschen
orientieren können da vorne der grüne
strich als glaube ich dass wir dort
vorhin uns selbst getötet haben
egal wenn ich das bei minecraft auch so
markieren würde ich mich aber nicht
schon wieder an oder
was ist an ihren scheiß problem dass sie
ganz so viel los etappe nichts gedrückt
ich wollte im sport und mit den dinos
angucken und wenn ihr direktor der
massenschlägerei ich laufe jetzt einfach
weg
ich kann ich laufen
es geht nicht
meine gesundheit ist bei 4
es ist wieder da
ich will kann ist ob die new school und
entwürdigt vor dem kombi getötet das
hört sich an wie ein leck aus dem
tiefkühlregal
ich weiß du bist gerade aufgewacht und
hast ein tamagotchi in der hand und das
ist unser nächstes bauen
wo wir vorher
dafür fallen die
noten ich sag's euch bestimmt darüber da
waren direkt wieder diese kopie kumpan
oder wie die da hießen und werden nicht
niederaden greift wieder töten ich will
einfach da aber
das ist wahrscheinlich der bruder vor
dem attentäter getötet ab du willst
verletzt ich weiß schon
jetzt ist krieg
jetzt ist krieg ja du hast damals china
an wir haben es begriffen wie scheiß
mantarochen da vorne vielleicht ist ja
irgendwie so ein spiel ist ein bisschen
aggressionen abbauen gegen den baum
vielleicht müssen wir einfach eine
andere richtung einschlagen also hier
vorne hat sie offensichtlich nicht
geklappt da wurde mir von einem mann
getötet wir wurden von einem kombi
getötet wir wurden von uns selbst
getötet seit sollten einfach hier vorne
in die lange laufen kommen hier vorn
haben den flamingo stehen endlich meint
ihr was ich auch keine omega erst noch
in
der euch gar nicht gesehen
das ist ein weiblicher shops können wir
noch ein bisschen abstand ja ich wollte
mit den familien hier vorne komme sogar
zwei sind ja keine - das sind droht das
hey
wie gehts hier
auch immer beide sind sauer
ich bin jetzt mal von der insel hier
wieder rüber geschwommen zur anderen
seite wir haben hier auch dodos ich
hoffe nur dass diese blöden kleinen
dinger nicht wieder zurückkommen werden
jetzt nicht so ganz freundlich aus aber
heftig wegkommen händen ist auch so ein
hochhaus
genauso wie das
aber gut wir haben hier irgend einen
kleinen weg ich weiß nicht von wem der
gemacht wurde wahrscheinlich von welchen
die nuss die hierher getrampelt sind
mein ziel ist es erstmal nach der oben
zu laufen und kleinen überblick zu
verschaffen ich bin ganz ehrlich der
start war jetzt nicht sonderlich
erfolgreich wir sind dreimal gestorben
haben bordeaux außer den angegriffen und
generell eigentlich noch nicht so
wirklich erreicht aber trotzdem level 3
upgrade hinbekommen
[Musik]
das ist ein
triceratops glaube ich
ich glaube die mögen menschen nicht so
gern
von daher besser abstand halten da
hinten die kämpfen
oder die paten sich ich weiß ich dass
die fed ihren beides gleiche aus
allerdings lassen wie die da hinten mal
in ruhe ihr komisches ding machen und
schauen uns hier mal ein bisschen um wir
können hier vorne vielleicht sogar oft
den stein auf klettern um uns mal so ein
bisschen den überblick zu verschaffen
hallo er sei ja wieder davon haben wir
doch sondern schildkröten dingen da ganz
hinter läuft doch irgendwie was links
läuft was die da hinten aber die sind
extra
das ist ja wie eine raupe auf lackiert
ist
dass der kern drehen es kommt manchmal
dass er nächsten näher an ein paar
sekunden später
der ihnen gerade getötet
und
ich hasse dieses spiel